[Música]
y
el anuncio de las autoridades alemanas
de emitir una advertencia contra los
viajes a españa excluyendo a las islas
canarias ha generado un gran debate en
este país en los últimos días no
solamente por la eficacia de la medida
sino también por el posible impacto que
puede tener por ejemplo en el sector
turístico y es que españa en general
pero las islas baleares en particular
están entre los destinos preferidos de
los alemanes fuentes del sector
turístico estimaban que la semana pasada
había unos 30.000 turistas alemanes
solamente en las islas baleares la
decisión de las autoridades alemanas no
solamente conlleva la cancelación de
muchos viajes organizados sino que
también obliga a los turistas a
realizarse una prueba de coronavirus a
su llegada a alemania y a permanecer en
cuarentena hasta que el resultado sea
negativo españa se suma así a otros 130
países y regiones que están en la lista
de alto riesgo de las autoridades
alemanas una lista que también incluye a
la mayoría de países de américa latina y
a otras naciones como eeuu y como rusia
[Música]
el gobierno británico ha impuesto
cuarentenas obligatorias de 14 días a
todas aquellas personas que regresan a
territorio británico provenientes de
siete países de europa entre ellos
españa y francia que son los lugares
predilectos de los británicos para
vacacionar las cuarentenas anunciadas de
último momento por el gobierno británico
ha afectado a millones de personas que
se encontraban vacacionando en los
países de la lista negra además de
españa y francia- se encuentran también
bélgica suecia luxemburgo malta y los
países bajos las cuarentenas no
solamente afectan a millones de
vacacionistas sino también a la muy
golpeada industria turística que ha
criticado fuertemente las cuarentenas de
14 días ya que causan un impacto en la
de por sí afectada industria turística
durante esta pandemia global
[Música]
en medio de la confusión se inicia a
aplicar en italia la obligación emanada
por el gobierno italiano de realizar
exámenes de coronavirus a las personas
que en los 14 días antes de llegar a
italia hayan permanecido o transitado
por croacia grecia malta o 'españa estas
personas a su llegada al punto
fronterizo italiano deben presentar un
test con resultado negativo al
coronavirus realizado en las 72 horas
anteriores al ingreso al territorio
italiano y quienes no tengan este examen
pues deberán someterse a un test a su
llegada a italia el problema es que no
todos los puntos fronterizos italianos
han recibido estos kits para realizar
estos exámenes y esto ha generado un
poco de confusión un poco de caos en los
aeropuertos puertos y fronteras
italianas lo que es seguro es que no hay
cuarentena obligatoria para los turistas
que llegan a italia a menos que la
persona resulte positiva infectada al
coronavirus
[Música]